what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and of course we are
still talking about that spider-man no
way home trailer now if you or perhaps
one of your friends is still doubting
whether or not toby and andrew are
actually going to be in the film this is
the video for you and i also have to
issue a spoiler warning because we're
pretty much going to be going over the
entire plot of spiderman no way home now
it's not going to be super detailed but
i am going to be talking about some
things that we've seen in the trailers
some things that have been confirmed by
the trailers and of course toby mcguire
and andrew garfield and again if you
have any doubt i think this video will
pretty much convince you that they truly
are in the movie also if you love marvel
dc star wars anything pop culture movie
and tv show related be sure to head over
to my discord because there are just a
ton of great people in there who love to
talk about everything and of course
we're still doing our spider-man
collectible giveaway all you got to do
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture leave some comments on some
recent videos that'll enter you to win
okay so check this out i've done a few
videos on a certain plot leak that i've
always said is real but now the second
trailer has confirmed even more of this
plot leak and of course this plot leak
talks about andrew garfield and toby
maguire in fact a lot of what this plot
leak said came true in the first and
second trailer and get this this plot
leak came out about six months before
the first teaser came out so again i
have to issue a spoiler warning if
you're not really trying to know too
much this leak is true and i'm gonna
line it up with the scenes that we've
gotten from the first teaser trailer and
the official trailer in this video but
again keep in mind this came out six
months before the first teaser and the
parts that we did see on screen were 100
what the plot leak said and now with the
second teaser we got even more
confirmation so this plot leak is real
it's true it's coming from somebody who
has seen the movie now it's short and it
doesn't go into extreme detail so you're
probably okay but still watch at your
own risk it starts off by saying that
peter's life is ruined after his
identity was revealed at the end of
spider-man far from home by mysterio
listen i did not kill mysterio the
drones did the drones that are yours
obviously this part we know we don't
really need to talk about it but the
next part says he is now facing trial
and matt murdock is his lawyer now if
you've been following spider-man knowing
home you've definitely heard this rumor
by now and perhaps you even saw a couple
of photos that were released last week
that really weren't supposed to be
released two photos that john campia
thought were fake one of them had a
peter parker happy hogan aunt may and
matt murdock sitting at a dinner table
together since these photos have come
out a lot of people have spoken up and
it seems to be that these photos are
indeed real so that's one check mark for
this plot leak being real matt murdock
will be peter parker's lawyer in the
beginning of the film it continues peter
goes to doctor strange and asks him to
cast a spell to make everyone forget
that he is spider-man why do i owe the
pleasure when mysterio revealed my
identity my entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
again keep in mind this plot leak came
out six months before the teaser trailer
so there was no way to know this unless
this person has seen the movie because
this was confirmed in the teaser and
this plot leak says something goes wrong
with the spell and they break reality
and bring five spider villains of other
dimensions to the mcu stop tampering
with the spell oh my god please stop
talking when you botched that spell
where you wanted everyone to forget the
peter parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
so this is confirmed in both of the
trailers in the teaser trailer peter
goes to doctor strange wong says don't
do the spell he does it anyways and we
can tell that something goes wrong but
strange really only says the multiverse
is something that we know frighteningly
little about and he tells peter to stop
tampering with the spell however in the
main official trailer dr strange says
when you botched that spell we started
getting visitors from other universes
confirming that it is indeed dr
strange's spell which is bringing these
villains in not the effects of loki or
not the effects of wanda but the spell
that doctor strange did we tampered with
the stability of space time
the multiverse is a concept about which
we know frighteningly level and that's
another check for this plot leak being
real but then a big one is that this pot
leak says that there are only five
villains now for the longest time we
thought they were six but from a very
long time ago this plot leak has said
five and it listed them the green goblin
from the first spider-man film doc ock
from spider-man 2 the sandman from
spider-man 3 and the lizard and electro
from the amazing spider-man series and
of course those 5 villains were
confirmed in the latest trailer and
here's where it gets juicy it says
norman osborne is talking to the others
asking what is the last thing they
remember and they all say the last thing
they remember is that spider-man killed
them now of course this part was
confirmed as well in the main trailer
where doc ock is saying you're chasing
ghosts
to fight ghost what do you mean they all
die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid peter asks what they mean
and dr strange says they all die at the
hands of spider-man it's their destiny
it's their fate the plot leak says
strange wants to take them back to their
original dimensions but the villains
fear that returning would mean that they
would return exactly where they came
from meaning that they would die again
and side note the sandman and lizard
never died so i'm not sure what they're
planning to do there but it seems very
clear that they are indeed the same
characters from the tobey maguire and
andrew garfield movie so we'll have to
see what they do on that one now here's
where it gets really good and we saw
some of this in the trailer norman
osborne manipulates peter into freeing
them making him feel guilty for their
deaths
you're not gonna take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have
everything you want peter fights strange
and breaks the key which is a cube that
held them captive and the villains are
now free they start destroying parts of
new york now this is huge and i'll say
it again this plot league came out about
six months before the first trailer and
it mentioned the key which is the cube
which we've seen in both of the trailers
in fact in this trailer specifically we
see doctor strange doing something with
the cube it looks like he's about to
send all of the villains back but peter
says i'm sorry and doctor strange says
don't and then peter takes the cube from
doctor strange
yeah me too don't
and then we see the two of them fight
now peter doesn't get very far and
doctor strange pretty much whoops him
but they still fight and this is
apparently going to cause the villains
to break free this is also why we see
the key the cube in the final scene of
the statue of liberty as well they're
trying to send the villains back now
here's sort of the grand finale and what
you should send to the people who still
don't believe that toby and andrew are
in it this plot leak says to stop the
villains peter somehow brings toby and
andrew to the mcu to help him there's a
big rematch between toby maguire and doc
ock and between andrew garfield and
electro the final battle is at the
statue of liberty with the three spideys
fighting the five villains and the last
thing that is mentioned in this plot
leak is i have no idea who the sixth
member is or when or how he comes onto
the scene in which we've learned there
is no sixth villain so that's again
another checkmark that this is real now
the main trailer showed the statue of
liberty or the reconstructed statue of
liberty that is now going to have
captain america shield on it we saw all
of these scenes that were mentioned and
of course that we'll call it edited
scene where we only see tom holland's
peter parker going up against electro
the sandman and the lizard according to
this plot leak is supposed to have three
spider-men in that scene and again i
mean the editing for the brazilian one
was pretty clear the lizard is
definitely getting knocked in the face
there and if this is truly the final
scene andrew and toby are definitely
going to be there fighting alongside tom
holland now for the most part this plot
leak actually just tells us what we saw
in both of the trailers it just gives us
a little bit of an idea of what's
further going on a little bit more
details but again the main thing about
this is that this plot lake seems to be
100 real on every account and the only
thing that's not accounted for yet in
this plot leak that we haven't seen is
andrew and toby showing up but if every
other part of the plot leak is true and
has been proven real by both of the
trailers then we can assume that toby
and andrew being in the film are real we
can assume that part of the plot leak is
100 correct as well which is the main
point of this video now it's the worst
kept secret in hollywood and i truly do
feel bad for sony it would have been
great if they could have kept it a
secret it would have been awesome but
it's still gonna be pretty dang awesome
because i saw how many people were
excited when we got the teaser when we
got the main trailer it's still all
pretty epic and i'm glad they didn't
show toby or andrew in any of the
trailers because i'm glad they're saving
that for the big screen but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and if you have any
friends that are still doubting be sure
to send them this video don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can find me on instagram twitter and
tick tock and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you